well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to your house hey um do I tell them what
happened before I left last week when we
took that romantic shower together
so Tommy and I we've been together a
million years and there was one house I
lived in my first shower that was great
it was like a fire a fire hose dumping
and was a big shower and you and I used
to shower together in the mornings very
romantic this is before work we had day
jobs we would get up sure 2005 jeans and
jeans showering together every morning
it was really sweet I would put a
shampoo on your head and you would suds
my bag and we made kissy faces and then
go to work now the next two houses we
always had small showers so showers are
out yep until now yeah we've got this
wonderful shower and with two heads on
it or whatever and it's really it's
miracle it's a miracle and so we know we
get the hey let's go take a shower
together it's been a good few years
since we've done that and it starts off
okay and then all of a sudden little
things like you're lathering your head
but extra hard and then now the suds are
like hitting my eyes you you like it
freezing cold I like it warm like a
person you don't like it warm you like
burn third-degree burns hot yes so hot
yeah that's a shower it's killing the
bacteria it's done and then my episode
I'm like okay but I'll let that slide I
don't say anything to you and then you
spread your ass cheeks you spread them
and you're not doing this as a joke
spreading your asshole open and then the
water is hitting your asshole and I'm
right next to you like really bro you're
gonna do that all right also clean it
out right yeah you don't think you could
be a little more discreet or just a bar
so when I put it in there that's it
and then you go what are you doing yeah
so clean my asshole yeah but you're not
supposed to take the bar and mash it
against the dirty part yeah you are no
that's what savages do I've always done
that because you're a bear you're not a
person no that's how you do it that's
how you do it but then you contaminate
no you contaminate the bar oh that's
what it was like damn one baby Oh
and then I made notes because I didn't
want to forget and then you farted in
the shower that was for ya yeah cuz you
spread your asshole and then you farted
and then my favorite unbelievable this
is it gets Wilder ah ah horking yeah
horking look knees next to me in the
shower I'm trying to cuddle with you
kiss your face kiss your beard I kiss
you oh yeah yeah you pee on me all the
time in the shower you piss on in the
shower yeah and all that I can even
tolerate until you blew snot oh yeah
that was the deal breaker for me you
were and then the snot came out all over
your beard and it gets stuck in your
beard and I almost vomited in shower
that's when I was like alright I'm done
I gotta go I almost threw up I'm like
it's like showering with a hobo
I got a vagrant who's never been in an
indoor shower before oh man you were
like it's a homeless person yeah you've
never been in a shower before that's how
I shower I forgot the horrors are you
like you got to clean all the pipes out
you know I gotta get rid of her all of
it apparently farted you spread your
asshole you whores look easy onion
snotting you pissed on me I didn't jerk
off that's the more the one boundary
left in our marriage or maybe yeah we
still haven't had that ever have a
whiten on you jerking him I've been
waiting for that to happen for years I'm
at the point now where I'm kind of
excited about this so sometimes now like
it cuz I used to be like really like ooh
be real careful yeah but now I'm like ah
just let it happen you know let it
happen well I just expect it now I'm
like come on she's gonna walk in there
what would you do finish you just look
at me would you make eye contact
probably maintain it or would you just
get out of here
IMed finish I think I would just be like
watch watch watch watch watch watch
yeah it's been a long time since what
that we've been you know together that
that hasn't happened yet it's kind of
crazy especially considering I do it
pretty often you know yeah where and
when to win the babies and here's the
other thing does I turn you on we have a
shower there's no bathroom door that's
one of those bedrooms where it just goes
in the bathroom yeah I know I've been
waiting to catch you in there when I've
done it in the shower a few times so
when I've been home yes O groats gross
it's probably when I've been with the
kid though right yeah I hope you're
smart enough to do it when I'm with the
baby as opposed to where when when I'm
walking free and maybe I'd come in and
well why would I have to worry about
that you're my wife David I don't want
to watch you jerking out I don't want to
catch you and have that horrible awkward
moment I didn't know that why would you
why would I want to catch you
masturbating it's not part of my light I
don't want to know it
I don't wanna need to know I would think
a lot of people would want to see you
because nobody wants to see you
masturbate really you look like a
homeless person
you know you keep saying you're blown
out you blow your nose too and as I jerk
off art and hork and everything as I
jerk off you yeah yeah of course
got to get myself worked up now I'm
gonna throw up